uh who are you a fan of right now uh
because obviously the bay is there's a
lot of dope Young Artists a lot of a lot
of guys who are low-key ogs like Simba
you know Simba's finally getting some
national recognition
um and he's been around a long time but
who are you [ __ ] with right now out
of out of the uh area that uh you feel
like you know could be uh up next to
represent the city properly man um I say
this [ __ ] named a lot to uh young Jr he
from the town he's fired he raw as [ __ ]
uh of course little Russell
um
I got an artist named Nims he really
turning up Ella heart and I'm really a
fan of him now because he's my artist or
nothing like that but the [ __ ] dope as
[ __ ]
um he's doing a lot of different [ __ ] he
do like reggaeton
he do he do all everything you feel me
but right now I mean Oakland I can't
speak with Oakland like that it's not
turned up like that that's why you feel
me the guy is back you know what I'm
saying and I'm gonna turn this [ __ ]
back up one time but other than that I
said Junior right now that's why he's
fired that's that's who I'm a fan of
right now you feel what I'm saying super
dope yeah there's some dope uh oh shout
out chippers too
yeah shout out to like baby gas is
though that's my boy
um stunt of man's dope stun a man's dope
he's one of them records it's gonna be
get played in the bay forever I was I
was seeing that [ __ ] in jail I'm seeing
all the football players doing it and
everything yeah I was like oh yeah he
moving